There's a very interesting development, which
is that Donald Trump has a serious primary
challenger.
Now, let me sort of [inaudible] explain
what I mean by serious.
By serious, I don't mean someone that has
any chance of actually beating Donald Trump
in the republican primary, but it's serious
in that it's someone who is more of an actual
republican as far as the perception of him
than William Weld who's running against Trump,
and his name is Joe Walsh.
He's a former congressman.
Joe Walsh told George Stephanopoulos on his
ABC Sunday morning show yesterday that he
is running for president and the Republican
primary against Donald Trump.
President points too often is just about every
poll shows more than 80% support for the president
among Republicans.
They don't have an alternative.
I'll tell you what, George [inaudible] look,
I'm running because he's unfair.
Somebody needs to step up and there needs
to be an alternative.
The country is sick of this guy's Tantrum.
He's, he's a child.
Again, the litany he lies every time he opens
his mouth.
Now everything is working against this guy.
Okay? Trump has a very high approval rating
among Republicans, but not as high as Trump
thinks.
Trump says it's a 95% approval rating.
It's more like 80.
According to a new, uh, Associated Press poll.
Walsh has a lot of exploitable personal issues,
including allegedly being a deadbeat dad.
The Republican National Committee isn't going
to support a primary challenge to Donald Trump,
but, and this is the dream, Joe Walsh might
be able to get in the way just enough to become
an annoyance to Donald Trump, which would
be really great.
Trump has a high approval rating among Republicans,
but it's not set in stone.
Many republicans say they support Trump merely
because they don't like Democrats and it's
their way of showing it.
But there is 21% of Republicans that already
does not support Donald Trump, and that is
a, a fifth of the party that might be interested
in an alternative Republican to Donald Trump.
The RNC won't support a primary challenge,
but they don't even really need to because
the goal here is not to beat Trump in the
primary.
In the same way that the goal of an impeachment
inquiry isn't to remove Trump before 2020
the goal of all of these ideas is to weaken
Donald Trump.
So do we on the left want people running against
Trump from within the Republican party?
Absolutely.
The stronger they are, the happier we are
to see it.
Democrats can just keep running their primary
and meanwhile, anything that could weaken
Donald Trump is a good thing.
Walsh running against Trump might lead to
some money being spent that otherwise wouldn't,
and impeachment inquiry would replace some
Trump campaign media stories with some impeachment
inquiry stories and that could damage Donald
Trump.
Remember 2016 was decided by 70,000 votes
in three states.
Any of these things that could weaken Donald
Trump or interfere with Donald Trump being
able to set the narrative, we should welcome
and we should encourage.
This is Donald Trump's strength.
When he sets the narrative and gets the media
in a frenzy, gets them spending three, five
or seven days on something that Trump benefits
from, or at least that Trump would prefer
they focus on other than some more damaging
thing that is good for Donald Trump.
Joe Walsh is a disgusting ideological clown.
He's completely unqualified to be president
of the United States, but Republicans already
voted in a guy who's completely unqualified
to be president.
By all means have at it.
Joe, see what you can do.
See what amount of support he can pick off
from the Republican Party.
And by the way, don't forget, and this is
like the dream scenario, if Joe Walsh can
get some traction with the fifth of the Republican
Party that doesn't approve of Trump, again,
latest poll from the Associated Press, 79%
of Republicans approve of Trump.
21% don't.
Okay, that's one fifth of Republicans.
If Joe Walsh can pick up 3% support, 5% support
in the Republican primary, obviously he loses
the primary.
That may be enough.
It may give them enough money and may give
them enough momentum to say, you know what,
I'm going to run as a third party.
Because Joe Walsh has said he's a terrible
guy, but he said he apologizes for his role
in helping to elect Trump in 2016.
If his goal is really to do anything he can
to remove Trump, he might say, I'm going to
run third party.
And they're, when you look at how close it
was in so many key states, Wisconsin, Michigan,
other states, Joe Walsh running as a Republican
could actually, I'm sorry, Joe Walsh running
as an independent could actually take enough
Republican votes away from Donald Trump that
it flips one state to the eventual Democratic
nominee, two states to the eventual democratic
nominee.
So this is not strategy for the left.
What we need to do is run a fair primary,
uh, and then get people to vote, get people
to vote who otherwise wouldn't.
Half the country doesn't vote.
Find people who already agree with us.
Tell them this was a very small margin in
this state and that state in whichever state
you should vote.
That's still our strategy.
But if Joe Walsh is going to create an annoying
distraction, like a mosquito that you just
can't get to get, leave you alone for Donald
Trump up until the republican national convention
and then might actually run as an independent,
he could single handedly hand a state or two
to the Democratic nominee and conceivably
turn this election.
It might not happen.
We should support it because it does nothing
bad for us and potentially does some good
things.
Yeah.
Uh, it's, it's an obvious dead end in what
it is in that Trump is going to be the Republican
nominee unless he were to drop out or something.
Who knows.
Uh, but it is not a dead end in that it could
have a real impact and really hurt Donald
Trump in the eventual general election.
If you disagree with me, tell me where I'm
wrong on the numbers.
Okay.
Uh, if you disagree with me for some other
reason, I guess also let me know, but the
real case I'm making is that mathematically
this could have an impact that is not good
for Donald Trump.